we've been there 20 years
clearly the the exit strategy is not
looking good uh biden has sent i think 5
000 6 000 more troops
to secure a peaceful transition and get
our people out of there okay
how long would we have to stay there to
we're never going to fix this part of
the world they're never going to want to
have a democracy the the people of the
taliban you think they're just going to
switch over their win their hearts and
minds how long much longer do we say
another decade another two decade till
2050.
you're 3 000. we're never going to win
this war you don't go in at all or if
you go in you win
you decimate you're here here's how i
see it not going
how long should we have jails
how long should we have jails yeah how
long should we have jails the jail
system how long should we have it should
it be just like 10 more years it's not
going anywhere we should get away just
let's just do 10 more years of jails and
let's let's get but that's jails in the
united states how long do we want to
have jails across the world but what i'm
trying to tell you is these criminals
hate your country
bro they hate america
i don't know any other way to say it
they hate what we stand for they hate
women being free they hate gays they
cannot stand the gay population if
you're gay in taliban they don't they
destroy you
no no they don't kill you it's a public
humiliation type of a situation they
have to make an example out of you cnn
says they're very friendly yeah yeah cnn
says well they're
they're screaming death upon america but
they're being very friendly about it
very bizarre that was her line yeah well
that's that's one lineup i i totally get
it
but the player does defend it no no
that's fine but not that look listen the
point i'm going to talk about just the
point one little line but that's a
pretty bad line by the way like they're
saying that they're not
that's kind of like saying listen you
know you know they they raped johnny's
mom but you know what for whatever
reason they just gave me this guy though
nice guy he's got a nice gift clearly
she said the line that you're missing is
she said this is the most bizarre thing
ever i just said like yeah exactly i
said that i said it is bizarre yeah but
that's kind of like saying same guy that
killed my such and such he just gave me
a gift that's very bizarre why would
listen you understand that's like uh
strategy behind it all i'm saying to you
is the following
i hate wasting money
i hate wasting money
i totally agree with you stand wasting
money
but bro i'm not gonna lie to you man as
a kid
tilt i'm 42 years old till today right
you know till today i have to sit
certain places in a certain way i still
have a certain level of paranoia 42
freaking years old i live in america and
i'm still paranoid
10 years as a kid i lived there
every day you worried you're going
places story on the news car bomb on the
bottom guy turn it on boom it blew up ah
everyday news
flagellating these visuals don't get out
of your brain as a kid
these are you know anxiety stuff that
stays in here
and a lot of kids are gonna go through
this bro and to to to to think about the
fact that
those 50 000 kids that you killed their
dads their moms their sister their you
know
brother you did that
they're not going away that's a rage for
a long time so here's the reason why i
don't believe world peace exists
is the following reason you know how
they say first you eat the apple and
then come sin right
how many people do i need to kill for
revenge to be uh stick around how much
is the back and forth so somebody kills
your uh uh dad or your mom or your wife
or your girl
what are you going to do you're going to
say you know what
as a muslim or a christian i believe in
forgiveness it's okay man don't worry
about it
what are you going to do
so then that comes back then so we are
so into deep right now to get back to it
yeah you know who's going to lose here's
who's going to lose
guy messaged me says patrick have a real
muslim on your show i've had muslims on
my show i'll have more muslims on my
show but
the point becomes
hey the extremist wow you know there's
75 of muslims are not extremists you're
right but 25 r is what bill maher said
on his show
when he's debating ben affleck and
they're both on the same side
politically this isn't about the
reasonable people this is about the
unreasonable people and the unreasonable
people are typically willing to go to
measures that reasonable people are not
willing to go to so for you to think
about pulling out today
you're in too deep buddy
you're just in too deep this taliban is
not going to forget you think 911
happened this is going to be 20 year
anniversary
whatever you're doing this 911 all i
would tell you is wouldn't go too big
uh what do you call it
not a big city i wouldn't go to anywhere
there's a lot of people out there just
won't do it not this 911. it's our
warning that another 911 is it's 20 year
anniversary i know that because this 910
becomes 20 years since i worked at
morgan stanley dean water i have an idea
a little man on the street for a 911.
but all i'm saying to you is
i'm all about saving let's get out of it
but uh you know are you basically saying
that we should have not left and and we
should have not left forever like we
we're going to be in afghanistan forever
here listen
i'll
answer the question with a question how
many more years until we get rid of all
the jails in america
yeah never miss the same exact answer so
once we go in we're we're in
once you arrest a person for a crime
you can't just create that system one
time
it stays
the moment you kill somebody
an innocent person
retaliation is permanent dialectic it's
just not gonna go away bro it's not
and unfortunately
whether you like it or not
america has been involved in a lot of
different things
we're too in too deep to want to say you
know and by the way okay let's just say
let's pull out let's play the game let's
play the game good bad ugly let's just
say we pull out
okay
um
who kind of wants to rule the world
china
what do they want to do do they want to
rule the world because they want
everybody to become a capitalist
no they want to rule the world because
they want everybody to think like who
themselves themselves like like the
china right
okay
so specifically the chinese so so let me
ask you a question here here's a
question for you maybe china's sitting
there waiting for us to leave for them
to come in and if they come in who
becomes the hero
china yeah they've already offered to
help luck did you see the article and i
think wall street journal by the way we
can come in and help you guys if we
people transition if we leave
if we leave us leaves
and china comes in
takes a hundred of those places they're
not gonna go to all the 800 but let's
just say they come and take under those
places
that city that country the afghani
civilians are going to
hate america for leaving and they're
going to say china's here to save us and
what would china be doing while they're
there
china just helping build infrastructure
provide protection provide protection to
who the taliban no to the afghan
government yes so then they're going to
go to war with the taliban
do you think the taliban wants china
there if china yeah but
you think you're dealing with a small
regime
let me ask you a question let me ask you
a question if china right now wanted to
destroy taliban do you think they could
do it yeah i don't think i don't think
the two point i i don't think that
taliban fears america because they just
have to wait four years i think that
they know that we got to deal with xi
jinping he's going to be here forever do
you think do you think if china really
we've had four presidents that have been
you're right between bush obama trump
and now biden so it's not like the
regime has changed the media yeah listen
afterwards
people say get out of afghanistan that's
not happening this is not a topic that
i'm saying is republican or democrat by
the way
i agree this is not a this is an
american issue no this is a this is an
american issue but for me
if you leave the alternative it's going
to be very ugly well we are leaving so
where is this you know it's going to be
ugly i agree it's going to be not going
to be pretty and it's going to be
decades but i i think look
did russia go to war with afghanistan
and what the 70s when was this
it's like the graveyard of uh empires
that's what they call it it's a problem
china if china wants to try and figure
out the taliban
good luck mr ping
the uh i just
go back there before the taliban is the
synergist in this situation and how how
can you be a synergist again going back
like with people that are being either
willingly willingly naive listening to
to stuff that they know is not real or
you have people that are outright lying
because all they want is to get their
way they don't care if the world burns
as long as their side rules the ashes
how do you create that center what
matters most in your country by the way
what matters most in your life in me
right now your life
my family okay so number one you'll be a
center just for your family okay you got
to bring your family together what's
number two after family
right now in in this environment freedom
country like yeah okay so then you got
to be a synergist to your country what's
third so family country what's third
everything else is a pretty far my
friends okay friends is third so you got
to be a uniter of your buddies like real
good buddies that you guys are friends
couple of them are having beef against
each other you gotta try to what
bring them together ride unified what's
next
diffuse unified glue no what i'm saying
to you is no he's asking me a question
he's asking a question about being a
synergist in an environment like that
like that no what i'm trying to tell you
is you can't yeah you can't
in a fam you ever had a relative that's
not willing to negotiate with another
relative
you ever had somebody yes okay what can
you do in a situation like that there's
very little you could do it's nothing
you can't do nothing about it you can't
do nothing about i got a couple guys in
a cup no matter what i do nothing's
gonna happen nothing's gonna happen
they're dividers i can't do nothing
about them well that's the whole thing
with the taliban and the perversion of
islam they have their thoughts and they
have their mentality you're not changing
what i'm saying to you is
we
as a unit has to be united we are not
we have to be united we're not united
we're not united so for us where we are
as a nation we are not united on this
issue you're saying we're just
not on any issue not on this issue bro
we're not united america does there are
american politicians that don't think
america is a great country that's a
scary thought
it's like working for google and hating
google how the hell do you hire somebody
to work for google who hates google
thinks facebook's better than google
rule number one get the hell out of
google well that's that's i think that's
a problem on the left and the right the
on the left you have socialists that
hate the idea of america and on the
right ironically you have
anti-government you know small small
government lovers in government running
a big government yeah the government's
not american we need to be very clear
not what i want the small government
people in our government because they're
going to stop the socialists from adding
government
so i i think that that's a that's a
mischaracteristic all i'm saying to you
is if we go at the space
uh and we think you know let's just pull
out out of everywhere and everyone's
going to be civil it ain't going to be
the case so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you